WE WANT YOU ONE MORE.
HERE WITH REACTION TO HOW THE
WHITE HOUSE IS FEELING,
KELLYANNE CONWAY.
KELLY AND, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE.
STAYING UP LATE FOR US.
>> OF COURSE.
>> Laura: ANY CONCERN FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE ABOUT WHERE THIS
VOTE COUNT STANDS?
>> WE ARE FEELING VERY CONFIDENT
THAT EVERYTHING THE DEMOCRATS
AND DR. FORD HAS ASKED TO BE
DONE OVER THE LAST TWO AND HALF
WEEKS HAD BEEN DONE.
THE FBI SUPPLEMENTAL IS
COMPLETED.
THIS IS THE SEVENTH FBI VETTING
THAT HAS BEEN CONCEDED ON JEFF
KAVANAUGH INCLUDING TWO JUSTICE
CALENDARS.
NOW IT IS TIME FOR VOTE.
WE FEEL PRETTY CONFIDENT.
I'M
LOOKING TO GET AHEAD OF THOSE
WERE STILL SITTING ON THE FENCE
BUT I WILL TELL YOU THAT THERE
THERE ARE SOME RED STATE
DEMOCRATS WHO HAVE A DECISION TO
MAKE.
TENT THAT NIGHT SEAT FILLED
THEY CAN GO AND BE COMPLACENT
WITH THE PROCESS THAT HAS BEEN
FRAUGHT WITH HYSTERICS AND
HYPERBOLE AND HYPER PARTISANSHI
PARTISANSHIP.
DEMOCRATS TRYING TO UNDO
ELECTION RESULTS FROM TWO YEARS
AGO, I JUST HAVE TO SLOW DOWN
THIS NOMINATION TO GET AHEAD OF
THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS THIS YEAR.
THEY HAVE TO DECIDE WHETHER THEY
ARE GOING TO BE A PART OF THAT.
THEY OWN ALL OF THOSE PROTESTERS
IF THEY VOTE AGAINST JUDGE
KAVANAUGH.
THEY OWN ALL THE HYSTERICS COME
ALL THE CRAZINESS THAT YOU SEE
THERE.
I THINK WE WILL HAVE THE VOTES.
HE OUGHT TO BE CONFIRMED.
BY THE WAY, WHAT HAS HAPPENED IN
HER CULTURE, MARY MAGDALENE IS
CORRECT.
IT WON'T GO AWAY WHEN HE IS
NOMINATED.
IT'S ABOUT DIGNITY AND
INTEGRITY.
>> Laura: THEY ARE OUT THERE
TOMORROW.
THEY'VE A RIGHT TO PROTEST.
THIS IS AMERICA A PARODY OF A
RIGHT TO PROTEST AS LONG AS IT
IS CIVIL.
RICHARD BLUMENTHAL IN
CONNECTICUT, MY HOME STATE.
HE SAID THIS TODAY ABOUT THIS
PROCESS.
LET'S WATCH.
>> IT STRIKES ME AS REALLY AND
NEGLECT OF THE FBI'S DUTY.
THE FBI IS NOT RESPONSIBLE.
I THINK THE BLAME LIES WITH THE
WHITE HOUSE THAT STRAITJACKETED
THIS INVESTIGATION.
>> Laura: YOU HEARD THAT
THROUGHOUT THE PROTEST THAT THIS
INVESTIGATION WAS CIRCUMSCRIBED,
ARTIFICIALLY THE DEADLINE WAS
ARTIFICIAL.
THE REAL FACT AND GET OUT.
THIS WAS A RUSH JOB.
FRANKLY A CON JOB.
THAT IS WHAT THE LEFT AND THE
PROTESTERS WERE SAYING.
>> WELL, HE IS LYING AND OF
COURSE HE HAS A HISTORY OF NOT
BEING ABLE TO TELL THE TRUTH.
HE LIED ABOUT HIS SERVICE AND
VIETNAM.
HE DIDN'T SERVE IN VIETNAM HE
SERVED DURING VIETNAM.
THAT IS NOT THE DIFFERENCE OF
JUST A WORD.
THIS IS SOMEONE WHO SAT RIGHT
BEHIND HER LAST WEEK WHEN SHE
SAID I WANT TO TELL THE MEN OF
AMERICA TO SHUT UP AND HE
SMIRKED.
I GUESS HE DIDN'T UNDERSTAND
WHAT SHE SAID.
THAT IS ONE THING I AGREE WITH.
HE SHOULD DEFINITELY STOP LYING
ABOUT THE FBI AND THIS
INVESTIGATION AND WITH THE
WHITE HOUSE DID OR DIDN'T DO.
THE PEOPLE THAT DR. FORD HERSELF
SAYS COULDN'T COOPERATE WERE
PART OF THE FBI INVESTIGATION.
GUESS WHAT?
THEY COULDN'T COOPERATE HER
ALLEGATION IT TURNS OUT.
YOU HAVE THESE SENATORS WHO HAVE
VERY SUCCESSFULLY COME FORWARD.
I THINK THIS IS A THOROUGH
INVESTIGATION.
ONE SAID THERE IS NOT A HINT OF
ANY MISCONDUCT.
THAT THE ALLEGATIONS HAVE NOT
BEEN COOPERATED.
THE POINT IS THIS, THERE IS NO
NOMINEE THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
GOING TO PUT FORWARD THAT WILL
SATISFY LIBERALS.
THERE IS NO NOMINEE THAT THEY
WILL EVER LIKE.
THEY HAD TO ADMIT THAT THIS IS
ABOUT THE MIDTERMS.
BEING OF THE MIDTERMS, I WANT TO
THANK ALL THESE CRAZY LIBERALS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE DONE SOMETHING
THAT --
THEY HAVE ENERGIZED THIS.
>> Laura: FIVE MORE WEEKS.
>> THERE IS NO QUESTION ABOUT I
IT.
THESE FOLKS HAVE A RIGHT TO
PROTEST.
THE FIRST AMENDMENT SAYS YOU CAN